>>Male Presenter: And, welcome.
I'm Aditia and I'm here on behalf of the Personal
Growth Washington Group.
And also in partnership with Optimize Your
Life.
That's OYL.
You can find them at go/oyl.
And we're proud to bring to you today Dr.
Temple Grandin.
Who I believe most of you probably are already
familiar with.
So she's Professor of Animal Studies at Colorado
State University.
And a world renowned expert in animal welfare.
Particularly in the agriculture industry.
And on autism advocacy.
So we're really happy to have her today.
And thanks for joining us.
And with that I'll present Dr. Grandin.
[applause]
>>Temple Grandin: Well, it's really good to
be here today.
And let's just start talking a little bit
about what autism is.
Autism is a developmental disorder.
And it varies from very severe when there's
no speech to very, very mild, where it just
merges into a personality variant.
And when you get into the very mild you will
have Steve Jobs, and you will have Einstein.
He had no speech 'til he was three.
Nikola Tesla who invented the electric power
plant.
So at one end of the spectrum it's probably
just a personality variant.
Other end of the spectrum, a very, very severe
handicap.
And if you were to get rid of all of the genetics
that makes autism, well, probably anywhere
from 25 to 50 percent of the people that work
here.
You're not gonna get any new employees.
It's gonna be just that simple.
And there's many other people in Silicon Valley
that I know are on the spectrum.
Big names but I won't mention them by name
'cause they're still living.
And all of the information I've gotten on
Steve Jobs has come from publicly available
sources like the book, Business Week Magazine,
and other sources.
He was a kid that had a lot of problems in
school.
He was teased.
And he had to switch to another school.
He was very lucky to go into the Cupertino
Valley High School, where there was lots of
other tech people.
And people doing interesting things in their
garage.
And he got into a computer club.
You know, we're gonna look at how do we get
some of these kids that are kinda floundering
around, into really good things?
Well, it's through shared interests.
The way Steve Jobs got into the industry was
getting into a computer club.
Other people with similar, like interests.
And the genetics of autism is real complicated.
It's a whole lot of little tiny small gene
variations.
And as you have, people get married and have
kids and the more it concentrates, the more
likely you are to get autism.
In its mild form, it can give you an advantage.
In it's very severe form, a lot of problems.
And one of the big problems that educators
have is a lot of special educators, they're
well trained to work with the more severe
kids.
But they don't know what to do with the smart
math geek kids.
Lucky ones, they'll get off into advanced
placement.
The unlucky ones, they'll make 'em drill 'em
over and over and over again, over and over
again on the same stuff.
And they're going to get really bored and
they're gonna hate school.
And that's not gonna be a good thing.
Around here, I know that a lot of the companies
around here reach out to the high schools.
But then I go out to the Midwest and I see
smart kids that ought to be working here.
And they're going absolutely no where.
They're getting addicted to video games.
And they're ending up on Social Security in
the basement playing video games.
And if they were getting programming jobs.
Designing video games that'd be one thing.
But that's where a lot of them are just simply
aren't going there.
Now I want you to think about different ways
of thinking.
You know, most of, a lot of people here, you're
mathematical thinkers.
And I am an extreme visual thinker.
And I wanna talk about how different kinds
of minds can work together on projects.
'Cause there are different ways of thinking.
I've done a lot of work with animals.
And being an extreme visual thinker helped
me.
Because to understand animal, you gotta totally
get away from verbal language.
It's a world of pictures.
A world of sound.
A world of little detailed sensory sensations.
It's not abstract.
Now when Van Gogh painted "Starry Night",
I don't think he realized that he was painting
mathematics into "Starry Night."
You see, underneath language, there's all
the fun stuff.
Mathematics, art, things like that.
And some statisticians got a hold of this
and found mathematics in it.
There's also a type of Alzheimer's where as
the person's frontal cortex and language parts
of the brain get wrecked, visual thinking
comes out.
And this painting was done by somebody with
Alzheimer's.
And then eventually the whole brain is trashed.
And then you've got thinking in details.
You see, the kind of thinking that I have
is bottom up.
I form concepts by putting specific pictures
into file folders in my brain.
Everything is learned by specific example.
Rather than having a big overriding theory.
So this is kind of a classic gestalt test.
And the person on the spectrum, they can identify
the little letters a lot faster than the big
letters.
Now there's some fascinating research that
shows that the normal brain drops out details.
Well, you know in programming, details are
really important.
Things are not gonna work.
So if you take somebody on the autism spectrum
and you put them in a scanner.
And you have them read out of a book, the
scanner gets all turned on in the part of
the brain where the words are processed.
Take the Asperger, which is this milder autism.
And put 'em in there.
You get the syntax, the whole, and the detail
of the words.
But then you take the normal person.
Guess what happens.
You lose all the detail of the words.
Now one of the big problems we have today
in trying to work on policy and a lot of things,
is you've got policy makers now that have
totally gotten separated from the ground.
From the real things out there on the ground.
Out there in a physical world.
The physical world is where I work.
I don't understand what you do in programming.
But I understand things like, you've got a
big valve and there's a solenoid to turn that
valve.
Is that valve gonna work or is it stuck because
it's been sitting there for five years and
has never been turned?
That's the kinda stuff I understand.
And I was asked in previous section if there's
any things that I'm concerned about.
Where we could have major screw ups.
Lemme tell you right now.
The power grid security.
That's one of 'em.
And the other big one is somebody wants to
make an all electronic car with electronic
brakes.
I'm not very big on that.
I think there's certain things that I want
made the old fashioned way.
Brakes that work no matter what.
Steering where I can still steer and I can
turn the whole thing off if I absolutely have
to.
I'm sure everybody heard about how they, the
Israeli intelligence agency hacked into the
Iran nuclear centrifuges and made 'em run
really fast so they destroyed themselves.
And that was run off a standard industrial
controller.
Well, how can I avoid to have that not happen
to a power plant?
And spin a power plant too fast and break
it?
Well, how about an old fashioned '50s style
control.
Goes too fast, it shuts down.
It gets too hot, it shuts down.
In other words, some controls where a computer
has absolutely nothing to do with it.
To make sure that something bad doesn't happen.
And the thing is, I don't understand that
computer stuff.
But I understand a lot of the old physical
stuff.
And we're gonna get into some other examples
of that.
Now right here, when I first started my work
with cattle, I noticed that sometimes the
cattle would go up the chute.
And sometimes they wouldn't.
Well, why wouldn't they go into this veterinary
facility?
Because the flag was there waving.
Sometimes the most obvious is the least obvious.
They wanna rip up the whole facility rather
than simply move the flag.
It's so obvious.
Alright.
Let's think about some more things.
The Japanese nuclear power plant accident.
I read everything I could find about that.
And I'm going "How could they have done this?"
How could they have let four reactors burn
up?
Because they live by the sea.
And they put the emergency generators that
run the really important cooling pump that
keeps the plant from blowing up, in the basement.
So when the seawall was breached, the basement
filled up full of water.
Guess what happens.
Electric power boards, diesels.
They do not work under water.
And that's why four nuclear power plants melted
down.
Well, I'm now beginning to find out that the
problem is, they really didn't see it.
I can't design a nuclear power plant.
But I can visualize all kinds of physical
things that could go wrong.
Like generators getting flooded.
I wouldn't make that mistake.
Let's look at another mistake, that the visual
thinker can discover.
Airbags killin' babies and children.
OK.
So you follow the spec.
It's gotta hold an adult man with no seatbelt.
Well, then it kills babies.
And I wouldn't have made that mistake either.
But I'm really beginning to think that there's
different kinds of minds.
And the problem is, they just didn't see it.
OK, and my cattle work.
Look at how that animal like walked right
onto that sunbeam.
It seems so obvious when you look at that
picture.
But it wasn't obvious.
And when I first started working on this,
I talked about these things.
And this was back in the early '70s. people
thought I was crazy.
To even think about what a cattle was looking
at.
So I'd get down the chutes and I'd see, what
are the animals seeing?
Down in the chutes?
Look at the shadows.
I always get asked, do the cattle know they're
gonna get slaughtered?
That's a question I had to answer very early
in my career.
And not gonna show any slaughter pictures.
Don't worry.
I, and, I found they behaved the same way
at the Swift Plant as they behaved at a veterinary
chute out on a ranch or a feed yard.
No.
They are afraid of things like, it's too dark.
There's a reflection on a piece of metal.
There's a puddle.
They can see people walkin' by.
And if you get rid of these distractions,
then they walk right up the chute.
No.
They were afraid of visual things that they
saw.
Well, let's look at things like which way
is the animal pointing its ears?
That seems pretty obvious.
But sometimes things that are obvious aren't
all that obvious.
OK.
What exactly is photo realistic visual thinking?
It's pictures in your head like movies.
Just a picture a young autistic man sent to
me to show how he has movies in his head.
And those are 16 millimeter movie reels.
Those are really, really dated.
And one thing I liked in the HBO movie is
they showed all my projects accurately.
I actually did build that optical illusion
room.
Well, I wouldn't have gotten interested in
things like that if I hadn't had a science
teacher expose me to those things.
Now let's think about different kinds of thinking.
And when I wrote my book my early book, "Thinking
In Pictures", I realized my thinking was different
when I asked people about church steeples.
Think about a church steeple.
How does it come into your mind?
I was shocked to find out that most people
get this vague generalized one.
I always see specific ones.
My concept of what a church steeple is, is
a whole bunch of different pictures of specific
ones.
How did I figure out that a dog was not a
cat.
Well, kind of I just sorted them by size.
But then when our next door neighbors got
a dachshund, I had to figure, why wasn't a
dachshund a cat?
Well, I looked at her nose.
And the nose was the visual feature that every
dog had that was different from the cats.
No cat had a dog's nose.
So then I can even put the little dachshund
in the dog file folder.
Well, it kinda just flashed up in my mind
that churches do.
Sort of like Google for images.
And they just come up in my mind.
These still pictures.
You see, nothing is abstract for me.
Everything is specific.
Would you like a snowstorm?
Would you like a rainstorm?
Would you like a wedding procession?
I can give you that.
I can pull it up out of memory and put that
in the picture.
Now being this kind of visual thinker helped
me in my livestock stuff, 'cause I could actually
test run equipment.
And now I'm thinking about right now, I'm
seeing, I'm kind of imagining this picture.
This poor Japanese guy.
He's up on some catwalk and he's looking down
at the drowned generators and he's going,
I don't know what the F--- word is in Japanese.
But he's going "We're in so much trouble right
now.
It's not funny."
Now you might wonder why is this curved?
Cattle have a knack for behavior to go back
to where they come from, that's why it's curved.
Half the cattle in this country are handled
in the equipment I designed.
I think that's doing pretty good for somebody
they thought was mentally retarded.
Because when I got into my 20s, I had gigantic
motivation to prove to people I wasn't stupid.
Now let's say you take some of these kids,
kinda geeky.
You know they're on the mild end of the autism
spectrum.
And they've gotten labeled with autism.
Often times parents and teachers don't make
'em do enough stuff.
I'm seeing kids that are smart graduate from
college and they don't know how to order food
at a restaurant.
They don't know how to shop.
They don't know how to do laundry.
They don't know how to shake hands.
They don't know how to say please and thank
you.
They've got to be taught these basic skills.
Because you don't pick up the social things
naturally.
You gotta be taught.
Now in the '50s, all kids were taught.
Really rigidly taught social rules.
So there's a lot of older people with Asperger's
coming out of the woodwork now.
Because their son or their granddaughter or
their grandson was diagnosed with Asperger's.
And now granddad or dad realizes he has it.
I had a NASA space scientist come up to me,
it was about six weeks ago, and he had a grandson
that was diagnosed with autism.
And he said "You know what?
I've got it, too.
And half the people in NASA have it."
So I'm getting concerned that some of our
smartest people aren't going down the right
track.
Because it takes a totally different kind
of education to train the smart person on
the spectrum compared to somebody that's got
very severe handicaps.
And they're not gonna be working at Google.
You see it's a very very big spectrum.
It's a continuous trait.
There's the dip vat they designed, they did
for the movie.
Which I originally designed for John Wayne's
feed yard.
The John Wayne, the cowboy.
And there's one of my drawings.
Now when you're a weird nerd, the only way
I could sell myself was showing off my work.
And I remember going to an ag engineering
meeting.
And nobody wanted to talk to me 'cause I was
just like a crazy geeky weird lady.
And I pulled out one of these drawings and
they were like "Oh, you did that?
Oh, you did that?"
You know, then I started to get some respect.
And that's how I sold projects.
By showing my work.
And this is another one of my drawings.
They actually put these drawings in the movie
and that really turned me on.
Now I teach a class where I have students
actually lay out cattle facilities.
Where they have to do an exercise in visual
thinking.
And one of the things you gotta learn is how
to relate the line on a drawing to the actual
thing.
The line on a drawing and then you've got
the thing.
And that's something that took me a while
to learn that.
[inaudible] a great big drawing of a whole
entire Swift Plant.
And I walked around that plant for two days
until every line on that drawing, I could
relate to a real thing.
Like this little tiny square.
It's a concrete column.
This big round thing, that's the water tower.
This big oval thing is a big vat they salt
cure the hides in.
You know where everything, I could, 'cause
a drawing was kind of abstract.
And I had to relate that to things that are
real.
So I do the same thing with my students.
But then I've noticed that a really weird
thing happens.
I watched the industry.
And I've done work for every major meat company.
My equipment's in every one of the major meat
companies.
And watching the industry going from hand
drawing, going into the mid '90s.
Switching over to computers.
And some weird things started to happen.
I started getting extremely weird mistakes
on drawings.
They did not know where the center of a circle
was.
They would have 25 foot long gates.
I mean there's no way that's gonna work.
The gates would swing wrong.
'Cause they never actually used the compass.
So I started tracking down these drawings.
And in every single case, they came from a
young kid.
Never built anything with his hands.
Never had done any drawing by hand.
I had these drawings from every single major
meat company.
Every single time, they came out of some young
kid and the problem is, to see things right,
you gotta touch.
There's a very interesting chapter that Oliver
Sachs wrote.
About a man who got cataracts taken off as
an adult.
And he looked at his dog and he didn't know
what it was until he felt it.
He had to feel it in order to understand the
image.
Now I've talked to a number of the animation
companies.
I've been out, I went out to Pixar.
I went out to Disney Imaginary.
Very very interesting places.
Boy let me tell you.
Fun office at Pixar.
I mean, they'll buy 'em tool sheds at Home
Depot and making them into offices.
Really cool stuff there.
But the other thing that was interesting is
this whole business that you have to touch
in order to draw.
Like Buzz Lightyear starts out as pencil sketches
on the wall.
And then they also have a 3D printer.
So they can draw a 3D drawing and they can
print out a little statue of the character.
And I noticed something really interesting
about those little statues.
Where do you think they had the statues located?
They were right there next to their computers.
So they could hold them and touch them.
Get that touch feedback.
So they wouldn't start making weird mistakes
on drawings.
What does a baby do?
It touches everything.
That's how it learns how to see.
You know now in the future, we can get things
to where you get the real touch feedback then
maybe you don't have to be dealing with the
real things.
But I get concerned here.
As I walk through here.
Everything is getting far away from the real
things.
OK.
We're gonna connect a computer up to a power
plant.
Give me an old '50s style governor hooked
up to the main disconnect switch.
Because that baby spins too fast, I want it
shut down.
And I want it with something where there's
no way to hack it.
'Cause it ain't gonna have a computer in it.
Just gonna be that simple.
I think there's some very important life-critical
things.
And very expensive things that would break.
Things that maybe that a computer should have
nothing to do with it.
Now, it has to do with a lot of other things,
but not that stuff.
OK.
When I was a little kid, I was good at drawing.
This is a drawing that a nine year old did
in perspective.
A big fan of building up the kid's area of
strength.
Because on the autism spectrum, also with
ADHD and dyslexia, you get a lot of crossover
between these different labels.
Don't get hung up on your labels as to whether
your kid's PDD, autism, maybe social communication
disorder.
That's a new thing they're gonna put in the
DMS5.
Build up strengths.
You've got uneven skills.
Build up the area of strength.
Can't emphasize that enough.
Also diagnosis is not precise.
It's a behavioral profile.
It's not precise like a diagnosis of tuberculosis
is precise.
You got doctors sitting around in conference
rooms, fighting each other on what the DMS5,
the next diagnostic guideline, should have.
Nobody sits around a conference room and tries
to remake the diagnosis for meningitis or
some disease like that.
It's precise.
Now I used to joke around that I had a huge
internet trunk line that went deep into my
visual cortex.
Yes I do.
Big huge graphics card there.
Well, when I got these scans, it was like
wow.
This would explain object realistic visual
thinking that I had.
Because to think about anything, I gotta have
a real picture in my mind.
Now if somebody says to me, "OK, well think
about yummy food I just ate over there in
the cafeteria."
I see it.
And it's going "Oh, wow, gourmet this and
that, this is really good."
Now another kind of mind is your minds.
The mathematics mind.
The pattern thinking mind.
The engineering mind.
That does very well on things like traditional
visual spatial type tasks.
Where you have to rotate patterns in space.
I'm not good at that.
That praying mantis is made out of a single
sheet of folded paper.
No taping, no cutting.
What you see in the background is the folding
pattern.
That's certainly not my mind.
That's for sure.
Now this is an important slide.
These are the kind of different kinds of minds.
Now, you know, so called normal people tend
to be more even in the skills.
But you get people labeled with various labels,
you tend to have uneven skills.
And you can have extreme photo realistic visual
thinker like me.
Can't do algebra.
Can't do foreign language.
Just impossible.
Then you get the pattern thinker.
This is the music and math mind.
That engineering mind.
Often times loves foreign languages.
Because they can pick up the patterns in the
languages.
I can't do that.
And a common thing you can have happen, is
you can have a little fourth grader that's
brilliant in math.
And may need to be advanced ahead in math.
But he's going to need special ed in reading
and writing composition.
You don't wanna make that kid just do baby
math.
You know, then you need to have some students
from the seventh grade come down and teach
the kid how to do the more advanced kinds
of math.
Then you have verbal thinkers.
I think our society right now is getting taken
over with too much verbal thinking.
One of the big problems I think we have now
with a lot of policy makers is everything's
getting abstract.
You've got students graduating in political
science.
They go to Washington DC.
They've never worked with anything practical
on the ground.
Well, they don't think about "Well, if I do
this policy how is it gonna affect something
on the ground, out there in the real world?"
Well, just to show there are different ways
to do mathematics.
And there are some people who would say that
algebra is a prerequisite for geometry.
And I think that's just rubbish.
Because geometry was invented first.
So how could it be the prerequisite for Algebra?
And education has an awful lot of big top
down thinking.
You know they get on these fads.
Well, actually what works the best is having
a variety of schools.
So that different thinkers can get into educational
programs that are gonna work for them.
We need to be having a lot more emphasis on
what's a kid gonna do when he grows up?
You know, there's a shortage of things like
diesel mechanics.
Machinists.
Some of the very high skilled physical trades.
There's a real shortage.
We need these people.
Well, you certainly need 'em to make the power
supplies for your Data Center.
There's some heavy duty hardware there.
You're not gonna sit and make it on a computer,
that's for sure.
This picture shows how this, how the autistic
mind is sorting pictures into categories.
You see to understand a concept, I have to
put specific examples into boxes in my mind.
A dog will do that, for example.
When I'm on the leash, I protect my owner.
When I'm off the leash, I can go play.
You see, that's a different picture.
If you think about it that way.
It's different.
A horse will do that.
Man on the horse, man on the ground.
A horse views that as two totally different
things.
If he was treated badly by a rider.
He may have bucked you off when you tried
to ride him.
But he'll be really good about doing shoeing
and veterinary work.
Because somebody on the ground never did anything
bad to him.
Now I find that when people are doing troubleshooting.
When they're trying to figure out what's wrong
with a piece of equipment.
People have a hard time differentiating between,
is it a people training issue or is it a equipment
design problem.
And is it a big equipment design problem,
or is it just a glitch.
You know like stuck trolleys in a meat packing
plant.
That'd be just a glitch.
You know, just to sort of categorize these
things out.
I find a lot of people have a hard time doing
this.
It's very very easy for me.
Alright.
Let's look at something like British Petroleum.
Well, they had lots of safety rules.
You go visit one of their rigs.
You better have a lid on your coffee cup.
You don't have a lid on your coffee cup and
you spill coffee, you might fall on the stairs
and you might hurt yourself.
But they forgot about the stuff that's really
important.
How about Process Safety?
They were doin' all kinds of bad stuff.
Rushing.
Cuttin' corners.
Not doin' things right.
Yeah.
Sloppy, sloppy, sloppy, sloppy.
They forgot about the real important stuff.
Now the thing is, both animals and people
with autism are bottom up thinkers.
All the different kind of autistic minds tend
to be a bottom up thinker.
Now the thing about bottom up thinking is
to be really good, you got to fill up the
database with lots of information.
Like I read and I read and I read and I read.
So when I go out and I do troubleshooting,
I go "Oh, well this problem at this plant,
that was sort of like the Jones plant over
there.
And we did such and such.
We added a light to the entrance of the restrainer
and they'd walk right in."
So you gotta fill up the database.
I say to parents, get these kids out and show
them all kinds of stuff because they got a
really good Google installed in their head.
But you gotta fill 'em up with web pages.
You gotta put web pages in them.
Bottom up thinking forms concepts by categorizing
specific examples.
A very important concept, educatin' these
kids.
Top down thinkers get the concept first.
But soon they're getting so far away from
the real world that the practical things that
they've, they just don't sorta get it.
Bottom up thinking makes it easier to put
information into different categories.
Actually there's neuroscience research that
shows that the brain makes categories.
But these mechanisms often times they kinda
cover it up with a more top down thinking.
We need to be working on how the different
minds can work together.
You know, a lot of the things we need, so
many safety things, is a visual thinker to
design the safety system at the nuclear power
plant.
How could you put those generators in the
basement?
Yeah, you had a backup and a backup.
But they were all in the basement.
So they all drowned.
There was no backup to the sea wall.
And the thing that's really bad is up on the
hill next to the plant there was a granite
slab put in the ground.
And it was put there a hundred years ago and
it said "Don't Forget.
Tsunamis come up to here."
And the people in the town knew about that.
Not good.
So we need different kinds of thinkers to
work together.
I mean lets go back to Steve Jobs.
He wasn't a programmer.
He was an artist.
He was all about the user interface.
Engineers have to make the inside work.
You see?
This is where different minds work together.
One of the things I loved about Google when
it first came out was I didn't have to learn
anything.
It was so simple.
You know, the last technophobes like me can
learn how to use it.
That's what I like.
When different kinds of minds work together
we can do really great things.
I'm getting very concerned that too many smart
students are going nowhere.
So one geek gets to go to heaven.
He gets to come here.
Another geek, especially out in the Midwest
is going nowhere.
Some of them get so depressed, they've committed
suicide.
It's just terrible.
Other, they adjust to playing video games
and are on Social Security.
See 'cause the problem that we have in the
schools is that this label, whether it's autism
or Asperger's syndrome goes all the way from
Steve Jobs or Einstein down to somebody that's
definitely not gonna be working here.
It's such a big spectrum.
And it's like two big kind of pieces of it.
It takes one kind of education on the higher
end.
And other kind of services on the lower end,
and a lot of the special educators are much
better at working with the more severe kids.
But I'm seeing smart kids getting into a bunch
of classes with the lower functioning kids
and they're going absolutely nowhere.
You get into school where they've taken out
all the hands-on classes.
They've taken out science labs.
And they've taken out art, and they've taken
out music.
And they've taken out woodshop and auto shop
and all those kinds of things.
Those are the classes that get a lot of those
people's kids going.
That's what kept me going.
If I hadn't had art, I would have gone absolutely
nowhere.
Another thing is, we don't have enough science
teachers.
I'm very, very concerned about how the public's
getting further away from science.
I went into a bookstore in Seattle airport.
And I was shocked to find out there was no
science section.
They had a very big section on history and
biography.
But not on science.
Now that wasn't the case 10 years ago.
I think this is very, very worrying.
And I know that a lot of the companies here,
Boeing and Google have reached out to the
schools here.
We need to be thinking about ways to get much
more out there.
I think what you're doing with SketchUp's
really great.
In fact I have a slide where I show SketchUp
and I talk about things that Wolfram Mathematica,
you know, mathematics site, and things like
that.
Well, my science teacher saved me.
Because he got me interested in studying.
'Cause now I had a goal.
Because I wanted to be a scientist.
And I'm concerned that our educational system's
failing to stimulate some of these different
minds.
The visual thinker.
The pattern thinker.
Now, there are some educators, even 10 years
ago or so, they're worried that we're overlooking
a lot of the visual spatial thinking.
'Cause there's sort of a politically correct
thing now, that everybody's mind's the same.
Well, you get in the middle of sort of humanity,
that's more so.
But I don't agree with Malcolm Gladwell when
he says that it's practice and access to services.
Innate ability does matter.
I had access to the exact same computer terminal
that Bill Gates had access to in 1968 the
IBM Teletype.
And I wanted to learn how to program that.
I couldn't do it.
I just couldn't do it.
You know and I had free instruction.
I had free access to the machine.
It just wasn't my kind of mind.
I think it's a shame schools have taken out
so many hands on classes.
I think it's just terrible.
These are the things that saved me.
Because when I did the specialized activities,
these were refuges away from teasing.
Steve Jobs was tortured by teasing.
And he ended up having to go to another school.
And that saved him.
You know and these kids get so depressed and
so out of it because they're just teased.
I talked to a lady that was my age that worked
for one of the big government science labs.
And she says "When I'm in with the engineers,
that's like being in with the grownups.
When I got stuck over in human resources,
that was like being with the children.
All they did was squabble and things like
that."
I'm very concerned that there's a lot of quirky
students, gifted students going nowhere.
Because they don't have a science teacher
to help channel.
And I think that we need these kids to figure
out the energy crisis.
The key to, 'cause what do they do with these
kids in China and India?
They become engineers and computer scientists.
I talked to a mom from India.
She came up to me in a meeting maybe seven
or eight years ago.
She goes, "Asperger kids.
Naughty.
Smart.
Send them off to computer school.
Engineering school."
But if they don't get exposed to these things,
they're not gonna get interested.
And I'm getting very concerned about all the
video game addictions.
If these things were turning into programming
games, fine.
Turning into paid employment, fine.
But most of the time it's not.
There are some exceptions where they do go
into the video game field and get gainful
employment.
I think big corporations need to invest in
the future.
I mean, our university system is just funding
cut, cut, cut, cut.
That's eating our seed corn.
It's eating our country's seed corn.
I'm very worried about that.
I just wanna talk about a few things in the
work place.
Where you might have somebody that's got a
little autism.
Maybe a little Asperger's.
Or maybe when they change the guidelines,
social communication disorder.
And they're making this new guideline probably
so they can get out of having to pay for funding.
They're doing it for that reason.
See the thing is, you disconnect a few social
circuits, then you get more circuits for art
or for math and that kind of fun stuff.
But you could also get in a lot of things,
ADHD, dyslexia, sensory issues.
Can't stand loud noise.
Can't stand fluorescent light 'cause I can
see 'em flicker.
The whole office is flickering on and off
like a discotheque.
I've gone into a lot of computer offices.
I didn't see that so much here, but, boy,
you go in the animation companies, oh, they're
in a dark hole there 'cause they got all the
fluorescent lights off 'cause they can't stand
the flicker.
You know loud sounds hurting the ears.
Well, there's a number of people who need
a quiet place to work.
Another problem is attention shifting slowness.
You know, they don't multitask well.
Now most of the jobs here don't require you
to multitask.
You just sit there and you do your job.
Attention shifting problems.
And some people when they go to read, they
can see the print jiggle on the page.
Because of the problem back here in the visual
cortex.
With the circuits that merge shape, color,
motion, and texture.
And to assemble that graphic file.
Something's wrong with that 'cause it didn't
grow right.
Print jiggles.
Let me tell you some simple ways to fix that.
'Cause I'm finding one out of 50 in my design
class.
And these kids cannot draw.
I ask them to just like draw that, they can't
do it.
And I said, "Print jiggle on the page?
Do fluorescent lights flicker?
Do you hate driving at night?
Do you hate escalators?
Well, why don't you try changing the background
color of the computer.
I mean light blue, light lavender.
Try printing your stuff on some light gray
paper or tan paper.
That sometimes helps."
And sometimes colored lenses help.
Pale lavender.
Pale pink.
But you gotta pick out the color that works
for you.
Nobody knows why that works.
But it's such a simple thing.
You'd be kinda stupid not to try that.
And then there are some of my books.
And one of the books I've got there is "Developing
Talents" and it's about jobs for people on
the spectrum.
Jobs for visual thinkers.
Jobs for the engineering kinds of minds.
And jobs for word thinkers.
Because I'm getting really concerned that
there's an awful lot of talent that's going
to waste.
Because there's all kinds of old Aspies now
and they're comin' out of the woodwork.
And the reason why they got diagnosed at the
age of 50 was because they had social problems
with their marriages.
But they managed to get good jobs.
A lot of 'em in technical fields.
Lot of 'em not in technical fields.
Not everybody on the spectrum is a technical
person.
Maybe a half of them are technical people.
And you got a bunch that are artists.
I think we're gonna end with that.
And we've got about 20 minutes to just do
some really, really interesting questions.
And discussion.
Because that's what I really like to do.
[applause]
OK.
We've got a mic here.
So we gotta use the mic so that the
>>Male: Testing.
Yeah.
>>Temple Grandin: OK.
Hopefully that's working.
And if nobody has a question I'll pick somebody.
OK.
How about right here?
>>Male #1: Is this working?
OK.
This is actually a comment.
It was an interesting point that you made
about the, these computer generated designs
coming from young people that wouldn't actually
work.
And gates that wouldn't close and things like
that.
>>Temple Grandin: All that stuff doesn't,
and the thing is these mistakes, the old timers
didn't mistakes.
Not these kinds of mistakes.
>>Male #1: Well, exactly.
No.
I was, the reason I mention it is because
I was talking to a woman who works for the
California Department of Transportation.
About maybe 10, 15 years ago.
And she said even back then, she was seeing
designs of highways, of roads.
That would literally be dangerous for people
to drive on.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, you have downtown
Denver, and you get in the right hand lane,
you're just forced off.
Ugh.
>>Male #1: Well in one case, she was saying,
the way they would do the crowns and the angles,
the slopes, as they would design the curve
around some obstacle.
So there's no car on the road today that will
stay on that road because they, they had no
concrete.
The computer said it was right, so it had
to be right.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, that doesn't mean
it's gonna be right.
I had a drawing sent to me that was a ramp
for a meat plant.
And for cattle you wanna do a three and a
half inch step and then an 18 inch run.
And so the [inaudible] going in didn't want
to form as much concrete.
So they went with a six inch riser.
And I was afraid the cattle would trip.
And I said "Put it back to a three and a half
by 18 inch step."
So they did that, and I get the drawings back,
and the steps went like this, and then just
straight.
They forgot that when you go with less rise,
you have to have more steps.
[laughter]
I am not kidding.
Major meat company.
Major name I'm not gonna say it.
That you see in the grocery store.
I'm going, you've got to be kidding.
It's happening and every single time I trace
these drawings, I'll call 'em up and I get
the kid on the phone and I talk to them and
I go "Did you ever build anything?
Did you ever hand draft first?"
No.
I mean I do this discretely.
But every single time this is what I have
found.
>>Male #1: The other thing is that since I
did some work in early childhood education
and developmental psychology.
One of the things, and in anthropology, one
of the things that seems to me really clear
that corroborates a little of what you've
been saying is that we've evolved over tens
of millions of years for the brain to understand
how the world works as little children.
And as infants.
Through that physical touch and interaction.
And without that there is this disconnect.
[inaudible]
>>Temple Grandin: well, and I think kids need,
I just saw something in a paper the other
day about giving kids blocks and having 'em
build things out of blocks.
You know, I think that's actually a good thing.
Because in order to see and, the brain is
works, you gotta touch.
To really understand.
And I think it's interesting and when you
talk with animation companies.
They handle their little figurines that that
3D printer puts out.
They don't put it up on some high shelf there.
They were all clustered right around the keyboard.
Right next to the monitor.
They're holding 'em.
[pause]
Now what do you do.
>>Male #1: [inaudible]
>>Temple Grandin: OK.
>>Male #2: I had a question about animal dissections
in schools.
'Cause you're talking about hands on learning.
And stimulating those visual thinkers.
But you get a lot of pushback from parents.
They're all like "Oh, I don't want my kids
cutting open an animal."
And kids that are like "No, I don't like that,
that's wrong.
That's wrong to cut open a pig for this."
That kind of thing.
And teachers that are kinda sharing that same
idea.
And I know that you're in a field where, and
you know, it's livestock handling.
It's that we raise animals and then we, for
use.
And not that they are things, but that we
have to respect these animals.
The question is, my biology teacher, she was
the only one who continued doing dissections
in school.
Everyone else looked at her and she was kind
of shunned.
Because she thought it was so important.
>>Temple Grandin: And how did you feel about
doing it?
>>Male #2: I thought it was incredibly useful.
It wasn't the same as the computer images
that show you how to do dissections.
>>Temple Grandin: Not the same.
And let's look at another thing.
One of the most attractions that most people
go to.
Like in the city of Denver, more people go
to the zoo than go to the stadiums.
You know, video isn't the same thing.
They wanna see a real lion.
>>Male #2: Mm-hm.
>>Temple Grandin: A real tiger.
It, they wanna see the real thing.
And I think we can get so far removed from
the real world that it can be very bad.
Because, when I look at some of the stuff
going on in Washington.
I go down to Washington DC it's like going
to the Twilight Zone.
Everything is just turned into posturing.
Who's gonna win.
I'm a child of the '50s.
Man, we built the interstate highway system.
In the '60s, my generation we went to the
moon.
Man, we did stuff.
The problem is we've got people in NASA and
here that are still doing stuff but I get
kinda worried here as I walk through here.
And you might forget especially at something
like a power plant, what the computer is connected
to.
Because I understand that big gate valve that
won't turn.
You don't put diesel generators where they're
gonna get wet.
That kinda stuff, I understand.
And I, you don't wanna get so far away from
that that you forget about that stuff.
And you may need some people like me that
get some people out of heavy industry, that
worked in the maintenance department.
Heavy industry.
And they'll go "Oh man, you need to do that.
When that computer goes crazy that's gonna
destroy
the turbine."
>>Male #3: I've seen that many people that
work in software industry where indeed we
work with the computer in some kind of virtual
world.
They have side hobbies, where they actually
work with real things.
>>Temple Grandin: I think that's wonderful.
I think that's good that you're doing that.
>>Male #3: For instance, I like motorcycles.
>>Temple Grandin: Good.
OK.
Good.
>>Male #3: Keeps my motorcycles [inaudible]
>>Temple Grandin: I'm glad that you're doing
things with motorcycles.
>>Male #3: May other people do gardening and
all kinds of stuff.
>>Temple Grandin: That's good, I think that's
really good.
I think that's good because it kinda, you
know I think some of the local food movement
is an urge to get back and connect with the
nature.
And the real world.
And urge to get back to those things.
>>Male #3: My point is that people get some
balance in their life
>>Temple Grandin: Good.
>>Male #3: between these virtual versus the
real world.
>>Temple Grandin: Well I think that's really
good that you're, 'cause working on your motorcycle
that's a mechanical device.
But I'm getting worried.
And today when you, oh man, the politicians
they just fight.
They've forgotten about doing things.
How do we solve problems?
When I was a child, I mean, man, we did stuff.
There's also some research, that's so big
and expensive only government can do it.
GPS.
Well, the defense department put up those
satellites.
The internet, that was DARPA.
Advanced brain scanning, that's DARPA.
I got scanned on that scanner.
That was the scan that was shown on 60 Minutes.
That's not at your hospital yet.
The Boeing jet originally was a military tanker.
There's some very very big research.
I get worried about, the funding cutbacks.
You know, there's things, you guys are doing
really great things but when you get into
things that are totally new, it's like what
private company would have developed GPS satellites?
They, private companies can develop a little
gadget that picks up the signal.
And when the military degraded the signals.
Private industry figured out how to re-degrade
the signals.
And make 'em real accurate.
But private industry would have never spent
the kind of money that put that up there.
You know, there's, this country's gotta get
back to doin' stuff.
You know I look at, we canceled our shuttle
program.
The Chinese are starting there.
So that's turning on all the little kids over
in China, just like we were turned on back
in the '60s.
I worshiped the astronauts when I was a kid.
>>Male #4: Yeah, its' hard to imagine that
we probably won't be back on the moon in our
lifetimes.
But anyway.
Why don't people react differently, especially
at an emotional level, to animals.
>>Temple Grandin: What do you mean, react
differently?
>>Male #4: Mmm.
So some people as they grow up become more
emotionally dependent on animals.
And some never want to be around animals,
or fear them.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, in the autism group
there are some kids on the spectrum where
they just totally best buddies with a dog.
They really understand a dog.
And there's others that don't like 'em because
they have a sensory problem.
Like the dog might bark and hurt their ears.
Or the cat might meow and that hurts their
ears.
And so it's really variable.
But I kind of don't, I, some people really
like animals.
I find lots of times that people are highly
verbal, they don't get animals.
'Cause I've seen a lot of very, very good
animal trainers.
The dyslexic or ADHD.
But I had a student who's fabulous with animals.
She was an extreme auditory thinker.
She had very, very bad problems with her visual
processing.
The problem that I just talked about.
And she'd listen to the animal.
Like how it breathed.
And with tremendous auditory detail.
OK.
The mic over there.
>>Female #1: I think one of the things that
I'm hearing, at least, you saying, is that
we need to get our children outside.
And get the children outside.
Experiencing, playing on a playground.
Or playing, being out in nature.
>>Temple Grandin: You know the lawyers are
trying to stop all that.
>>Female #1: [laughs] Because I'm too, when
I started it was called programming not system
engineering.
But I was, again, one of those people that
everything I did I knew it was gonna have
a bug in it.
But if I went out and planted vegetables I
knew they were gonna grow.
And what they were gonna be.
It was sorta that same sorta thing.
>>Temple Grandin: Well there's a wonderful
book called "Last Child in the Woods" by,
I think it's Richard Louv.
>>Female #1: Yeah.
>>Temple Grandin: And we've got people are
getting totally removed from the natural world.
Just wanna mention before I forget, there's
an autism meeting where I'm strictly talking
about autism.
I'll be discussing a lot of medication issues.
Way too many kids given way too many medications.
It's over on Bellevue at the Meydenbauer Convention
Center.
I'll be there at 8:30 tomorrow.
>>Female #1: And one other comment.
We have a son who's dyslexic who's turned
out to be an engineer.
But you know, when he went through high school.
You had to constantly be at their teachers.
Because he was always on a knife's edge.
Because you know, was he gonna do really well?
Or was he gonna fail?
And it wasn't, so much depended on how the
teacher perceived his problem.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, mentors.
You see, this is where.
I know several kids, talked to quite a few
situations where you had a parent or grandparent
or maybe a next door neighbor get the kid
interested in something like programming.
Even teach him something really old fashioned.
Like DOS.
'Cause that's the only thing that momma knew.
But what that did is it got the spark turned
on.
'Cause I'm finding with most kids.
Yeah, there's some that go find the books
and do it all themselves.
But most of them, there's gotta be some instruction.
Otherwise he's just gonna play video games.
They start, well, let me show you how you
can make a game.
Someone's gotta start showing 'em some things.
>>Female #1: This son though wanted to write
graphics programs.
When he was three and four years old.
>>Temple Grandin: Alright, well then someone
needs to show him how to write graphics programs.
OK.
>>Male #5: I hope you'll forgive me asking
a personal question.
I think probably many of the people if not
most of the people in this room first learned
about you from Oliver Sachs.
>>Temple Grandin: Yes.
That's right.
>>Male #5: And subsequently we've heard you
on the radio and on television.
And I have to say, you seem much more socially
adept than the way Oliver Sachs described
you.
>>Temple Grandin: Yeah, well that was quite
a long time ago.
That was over 15 years ago.
The thing is, the person on the spectrum keeps
learning.
You keep learning.
Like Clair Danes did a really good job of
being me in the '60s and the '70s.
Oh and the movie is available, Amazon's got
it.
Keyword Temple Grandin.
[laughter]
But they, you keep learning.
You see an autistic person keeps learning.
You have to learn how to be in the plot.
I also take antidepressant medication which
got rid of horrendous anxiety attacks and
panic attacks I used to have.
I take a very low dose.
And I've got information on medication in
"Thinking in Pictures" and the other book
over there "The Way I See It" which I think
they're gonna run out of.
It's available over at Bellevue.
And it's available in book stores.
OK.
We're gonna pick somebody.
'Cause we still got some time left here.
[laughter]
>>Female #2: I just wanted to say there are
people out there that are working with this
younger population.
>>Temple Grandin: Good.
>>Female #2: I'm not a techy person.
I'm his partner.
And I have a degree in counseling and psychology.
But I work from a little bit different slant.
And it's because I have some ADD and I have
other things going on with me.
I'm a technical kind of person.
Mechanical technical kind of person.
So in my age group I didn't fit into those
programs 'cause I was a female.
And so.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, I fought that.
I was a lady going into a man's business.
And I really did put bull testicles all over
my vehicle.
[laughter]
That actually happened.
>>Female #2: But I went into this field because
I have a son who has got dyslexia and ADD.
And I wanted to help these kids.
So I'm developing a nature therapy program.
Or I have developed it.
So that these kids get a chance to get out
and experience nature.
And experience the physical part of that world
we're talking about . So.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, I think that was important.
Let's see, there was a question right over
there.
>>Female #3: First, I had a comment.
My mother very much enjoyed your movie, and
she felt it really helped her understand my
daughter.
Who is on the spectrum.
So that was very nice.
She's like "Oh, I understand the sound thing
bothering her now."
What I wanted to say though is, we both came
from agricultural and construction backgrounds.
So we had kind of a real world start.
But now he does computers.
And we're struggling on getting our own kids
as much of the outdoor and the physical.
>>Temple Grandin: Well, the real world thing
with coming in this morning you didn't know
what a concrete pump was.
[laughter]
Yeah, that's, you see construction stuff.
I don't know much of computer stuff.
But I worked for years on with construction
stuff.
So I go by a construction site I'm all lookin'
at the stuff.
>>Female #3: So far we haven't found much
better than sending them up to their grandparents
to play with the excavator.
>>Temple Grandin: The other thing I think
we need to be doing is when kids get into
middle school, they gotta learn work skills.
They got to learn how to do assigned tasks.
Like when I was a young kid, all I would do
is do horse head pictures over and over again.
And I had to be encouraged to maybe do the
whole horse.
Draw a picture of something else.
You gotta broaden out the skills.
Another bad thing today, even for normal kids,
is kids are not doing playgroups.
Three or four kids get together, make up their
own game.
You gotta negotiate.
You gotta teach these kids turn taking.
They're not learning those things.
I think kids when they're 13 or 14, they need
to do some jobs.
Because we're coming out with another book
"Different Not Less" about old Aspies, 50
and up, that made it.
They got a diagnosis because their marital
relationships were bad.
But they managed to hold jobs for their whole
life.
Every single one of them had middle school
and high school jobs.
We're not teaching job skills.
I think it's just terrible.
They've taken a paper route.
They can walk dogs for somebody.
Because that's something they're gonna have
to do it every day.
I had to learn how to use my art skills to
make cattle handling facilities that people
wanted.
OK there was a question right back there.
>>Female #4: Thanks for all your influence
too.
My question is, if autism and all those spectrum
disorders are genetically linked, do you think
there's something environmentally or culturally,
nutritionally affecting the numbers?
As well as people being aware of what they
went through?
>>Temple Grandin: Well, I think with the milder
Asperger end, I think a lot of it is just
increased detection.
And I think the other thing is, in the '50s
they pounded those social rules and so they
coped better.
I think there is some severe autism that's
increased.
Especially this regressive autism.
Where the child loses language at around 18
months to age two.
You know the plasticizers.
There's a strong genetic, strong genetic basis.
It's complicated genetics.
It's little tiny code variations within genes.
A whole lot of little code variations.
It's not simple genetics like Down's.
Or whether you have blue eyes or blond hair.
It's not that simple kind of genetics.
>>Female #4: Do you think pesticides or other
plastics are [inaudible]?
>>Temple Grandin: Well, I think the biggest
thing is plasticizers.
Androgen disrupters.
Like those plastic water bottles.
I don't think it's the greatest idea if you're
pregnant to drink out of those or have your
kid nurse out of 'em.
You know I'm usually not alarmist about that
sort of stuff.
But that's one thing that, I'm worried about.
That and pesticides.
Some of the stuff I've read.
I drink out of 'em.
I'm 64 years old.
I don't have to worry about it.
I'll drink out of it, if it's been in the
car for two weeks and it tastes like plastic
but I'm just not worried about it.
>>Male #6: Uh, hello.
I was wondering what your thoughts are.
I guess I kinda consider myself on Asperger's
spectrum.
It's kinda the whole, but it's been my whole
life, I'm high functioning, I graduated from
MIT, I work here at Google.
>>Temple Grandin: And what do you do?
What's your, what kind of, do you do programming?
>>Male #6: Software engineer.
So you know, surprise surprise.
[laughs] But you know the whole question may
be about six to seven years of my life, ago,
I heard about the term Asperger's.
Read about it at lunch.
Said "OK, sure that's me."
But then there's a question of how much do
I share that with other people.
And I'm kinda curious about your thoughts
about this.
Because I can just, I'm well on the range
where I can just, I've done my entire life.
>>Temple Grandin: I don't.
I don't.
I even now if I meet someone on a plane I
don't disclose.
>>Male #6: Yeah.
>>Temple Grandin: I think I, there's unfortunately
still discrimination out there.
I've, I get worried about some of these smart
kids getting held back by labels.
And you know, if somebody, I have dads come
up to me and they'll say "Well, should I get
a formal diagnosis?"
I'll just say "Read the books.
Keep it off those electronic records.
I don't want some Google app getting into
that.
Really don't."
And I would certainly recommend reading some
of the books.
The stuff I've found most helpful was the
personal reports from people.
And some of the brain research stuff.
I, but it's, I, you know, it can really wreck
your insurance.
It wrecked my health insurance.
>>Male #6: Really.
>>Temple Grandin: I was turned down by AARP,
American Association of Retired People, for
a broken nose.
>>Male #6: Hm.
>>Temple Grandin: You know that's BS.
And that was just used as an excuse.
And it's
>>Male #6: That was
>>Temple Grandin: I've, I've, but the thing
is, in the tech industry, you gotta lot of
Asperger genetics because if you totally got
rid of all those genetics, you're not gonna
have any mathematicians.
So I mean, you have a lot of social yackety
yacks that aren't gonna get very much done.
[laughter]
Because, the thing is, if you don't have people
in the world interested in things, you know,
the social people are more interested in just
chit-chattin' and socializing.
Which I'm not.
And one of my big concerns today is I'm seeing
too many smart kids just going nowhere.
They're getting addicted to drugs.
They're getting addicted to video games.
They haven't been taught any job skills.
Just goin' nowhere.
And the problem is, it is such a big spectrum.
And the kinda teaching and stuff that a mild
person needs is very different than the more
severe ones.
But it's all got the same name.
And when they come out with the new DMS5,
they're gonna take the Asperger's out and
just call everything 'autism spectrum'.
Well, that really makes it clear as mud.
Scientifically that's correct.
Because it's a true continuous trait.
But I'm seeing that people get locked into
the labels.
My kid.
PDD.
Pervasive Developmental Disorder or Autism?
You know what, it doesn't matter.
>>Male #6: Yeah.
That was about my experience.
That it wasn't worth getting any type of formal
diagnosis.
And people are saying "Why don't you call
a girlfriend."
>>Temple Grandin: I would wish people
>>Male #6: Basically my gist was, why do I,
near as I can tell there's no advantage to
me getting any formal diagnosis by a doctor.
>>Temple Grandin: No.
It's a disadvantage.
It can really wreck your insurance.
And what I tell most people your age that
are employed in a good job like this, keep
it off those electronic medical records.
But I would read, I'd read a bunch of the
books.
Maybe even go to some of the meetings.
Now why with a little kid would you get diagnosed?
To get services.
You see if you wanna get services for a really
young child.
You got to have the diagnosis.